are safe to say when Jim Cameron
embarked on making 3d the common way of
the movies I don't think he thought of a
big rubber dick flying through the air
and smacking a guy in the face jackass
3d alright safe to say if you've seen a
previous jackass movie you know exactly
what these movies are all about the
extreme in every sudden contrast of
making you laugh to tears and then
immediately making you gag to tears I'm
not gonna lie I have not gone from
laughing that hard to being like oh good
since probably the last Jackass movie if
you can watch all of this movie without
gagging cringing or closing your eyes I
think you should get a t-shirt that says
yes I am a sick bastard I would wear
that t-shirt and I would wear it with
pride
not that I'd be able to because I think
I gagged in this movie probably three
times but I mean the movies really
impressive I mean who thinks of these
stunts honestly some of them yes really
gross and littered with [ __ ] I mean
actually a lot of [ __ ] like actual [ __ ]
the movie had way too much [ __ ] but some
of the stunts really smart now I'm not
saying they're intelligent but I am
saying they're smart I mean they do
nothing in their lives except jerk
around and hurt themselves and get
millions of dollars because of us I mean
any way you slice it that smart
I mean of the ever epic jackass trilogy
my favorite stunts probably the
terrorist cab stunt at the end of
jackass 2 but in this one it's got to be
the steve-o outhouse ejection seat that
one I think I laughed at tears and gag
to tears all in the same second that's
impressive so if you go into this movie
not knowing what Jackass is all about I
don't know what to say
forty-year-olds acting like dumbasses
mature no for everyone no funny yeah way
too many dicks and [ __ ] though I'll say
that just way too much and there's a
really cool thing at the beginning of
the movie that's a total shout-out to
old school MTV if you watched MTV in the
mid to early 90s you'll know what I'm
talking about and it was awesome so
jackass 3d was a good be a pretty gross
time no alcohol required but watch it
hammered Joe saying yeah and now it's a
party and if you're prone to throwing up
at gross things I think it's your civic
duty to actually watch the movie because
if you throw up someone that the theater
has to get paid to clean that up and in
this economy you always got to help out
with job security and if you like what
you're seeing here you want to see more
than click right here to see more